针对孩子的感情，
可能也要看孩子的反馈，
看孩子和他的互动，
看孩子是不是跟他投脾气等等，
你现在就说将来是丧偶式育儿这个事儿的话，
是有点欲加之罪，
何患无辞。
但这个事情的本质是什么？
本质是你不爱他，
你不愿意跟人家亲近，
不愿意接受他跟你亲近。
这个事情我现在要不要离婚，
如果离婚的话，
我该怎么保障我的权益呢？
我今年27岁，
我对象是28岁，
我是去年的10月份结婚的，
我一年多了吧，
我现在想跟他离婚，
但是我还没有跟他讲，
我妈和我姐夫已已经知道这个事情了，
他们也没有说反对，
让我不要离婚什么的，
就是尊重我的意见嘛，
那我自己想清楚就行，
我们是谈了一年半的样子订婚再结婚的，
说实话，
这个时间也不是很长，
而且大部分时间都是异地的，
只有周末的时候可能才会见面的，
哪怕结婚一年了，
我现在也是这个情况，
我不知道是什么时候开始，
我可能就已经拒绝，
我是从3月暂的样子到现在这个时间段一直都没有夫妻生活，
毕竟结婚了嘛，
这是年3月暂和前面2月暂啊，
一月暂这种的有点属于勉强，
那个时候我还没有发现我已经爱他了，
我可能以为只是我自己不想，
懒得做，
我就这种事情吧，
现在我就反应过来，
我觉得我可能那个时候我就已经不爱他了，
我不想跟他亲近，
是不是啊，
所就不太想跟他有这种的，
这就是身体情况嘛，
这个可能跟他亲。
对，
但性格可能只是说亲情也是一样的，
以前跟她会过夫妻生活的时候是正常的吗？
是对你满意的吗？
还行吧，
那你以前谈过别的男朋友吗？
有的，
我一直认为她的家庭和我的家庭非常的配合，
他的性格也和我也非常的配合，
但是我想跟他离婚的原因，
一方面就是我发现我不爱他了，
我已经不愿意跟他有这种行为了，
还有不原因是因为我觉得他可能很难承担一个当父亲的责任，
那我们姐谈对象的时候，
他对小孩就非常的没有，
比如说他亲戚让他抱一下刚出生的小孩啊，
之女有这种的啊，
他就是我不抱，
我不抱很拒绝嘛，
他们家里边那边可能就比较尊重他嘛，
也不会强行让他抱到后面，
有一次就是过年到我们这边提亲的那种的，
就在我们家那边，
我弟弟的儿子当时也让他抱，
她不愿意抱，
我就说了他后面她就继续抱了，
抱着就哄小孩，
那怎么办？
大概10月份吧，
我侄儿他已经走了，
会跑了嘛，
那个时候我我姐她那边正好办宴席，
就没有人带他，
嗯，
让他去带着嘛，
我们就比较忙嘛，
别的事情他就会带着小孩玩一玩，
闹一闹什么的，
但是我感觉他对小孩儿可能不是很有耐心，
我觉得我对他没有什么希望，
我感觉他将来如果说我们俩谈对象以后呢，
他也只会让他的父母去照顾我，
他可能不会参与养育小孩的过程，
他可能像我父亲一样，
只知道挣钱，
不参与这个事情，
觉得丧老师的婚姻和我宁可不要。
我觉得他如果说我跟他提结婚的话，
他反能会说啊，
我会改，
我改，
但是我觉得江山一改，
本性难意，
我觉得这个事情不涉及到1就能养成的，
而且我们在谈对象和结婚这个时间段态差不多刚何3年吧，
这3年过程中我能感觉到他是属于那种年里灭活，
他是属于那种我不喊他的话，
他可能不动，
或者说比如说我让他扫个地，
他就会让我一起一起去干别的事情，
或者说我扫地他说那钱就是让我拖地，
让干别的事情，
他不会主动做这件事情了。
我知道我自己也很满意，
也不太对，
他父母离我们做的不是很远，
我平时周末回去，
他父母反能工作日的时候上我们家去打扫一下卫生，
打扫完卫生以后就回去了，
他父母真的很好，
我觉得我在他们家能嫁给他庭妹，
这个原因就是他父母真的人很好的，
我就觉得离婚的话不一定能离得掉，
我就想离婚，
我不想过这样的日子，
他父母又很好，
我就纠结这一点，
还有一点就是他之前的时候，
我不是10月暂结婚的嘛，
5月暂订婚，
10月暂结婚，
这个时间段我觉得其实有一点匆忙了，
因为那个时候去年我也很忙，
事情特别多，
工作也忙，
还有一些提升学历的事情也很忙，
但是找那种拍婚照照的呀，
或者说是那种办酒席选地址啊，
这些东西基本上都是属于我去操持的那种，
他就可能就是父母钱啊，
或比如说去地方的话，
他开个车把他送过去那种，
他就说在旁边做个参考，
他不出什么意见的，
我就感觉好恐怖，
我就感觉。
将来以后我觉得他不可能像我父亲一样只负责出钱，
我有点害怕，
我之前的时候我跟他说过一件事情，
他跟我说什么，
他并没有催过我着急结婚，
让我不要给自己的压力，
但是我在我的这里听过来就感觉是不是很想跟我结婚的那种感觉，
我觉得这个事情是这样重要啊，
当时人家给彩礼了嘛，
他给了，
他给了多少彩礼啊，
我要的188000，
然后他父母说不给我3000，
就直接给了我，
他父母给我十二万六，
因为你俩结婚时间短，
就一年的时间，
如果你要跟他分手的话，
彩礼是要退一部分的，
我你能接受吗？
我可以接受啊，
我觉得给他退很多我都是能接受的，
因为我觉得我好像对不起他一样，
但是我又不想有这种像我师婚姻，
我觉得这个事情都是有点欲加之罪，
何患无辞了啊。
第一，
你是通过他不愿意报亲戚的小孩去判断他将来会丧偶式的育儿，
这个是不严谨的，
因为男人对孩子的感情，
他不是天生就有的，
男人对孩子的感情可能也要看孩子的反馈，
看孩子和他的互动，
看孩子是不是跟他头脾气等等，
你现在就说将来是丧偶式育儿这个事儿的话，
是有点欲加之罪，
何患无辞？
但这个事情的本质是什么？
本质是你不爱他，
你不愿意跟人家亲近，
不愿意接受他跟你亲近，
这个事情我觉得这个也能理解啊，
因为人跟人感情这个事情不能勉强亲近。
夫妻生活这个事情也不能勉强，
如果你已经不愿意跟他亲近了，
那我们就坦诚的面对自己的内心，
在经济上不要让人家吃亏，
因为毕竟是因为我，
我自己的判断出了问题，
我原来愿意跟你计较，
我现在不愿意跟计较了，
所以这个是我自己的判断出了问题，
我在经济上尽量给人家退钱，
咱们好合好散，
这个没有毛病。
所以我觉得我评论是有些人说我也有错，
我不知道我哪里有错，
因为我们两个都是各自的生活的，
他也个挣钱，
不存在错不错的问题，
真实的面对自己的感受，
面对自己的身体，
面对自己的欲望，
真实的面对这个点，
这个没有什么对错，
我觉得如果说在经济上没有让人家吃亏，
人家也不会说找咱什么太大的麻烦，
是不是，
是的，
我可能因为有点紧，
因为那么多人看的我有点紧张，
所以我说话有点语无伦次的，
其实我现在都很紧张，
我不知道怎么去表达我的意思，
我们只是就通过他这件事情，
还有想跟我们会沟通，
就是带小孩这个事情，
当然要生小孩的事情，
他就会有点比我还逃避的事情，
给我的感觉就是没有希望，
也有一种可能，
人家也没有做好思想准备，
非得跟你生孩子，
人家也没有做好这样的准备，
说因为你也懒，
他也懒，
人家也想我要是生个孩子，
我老婆也懒，
我也懒，
Coco呢，
人家可能也还想这个问题呢，
对，
但他是独生子，
我不想生，
但是我觉得我肯定以后还是会生一个的，
他家里面也不可能说。
让他不生小孩的那种的，
我们早晚要生一个，
那生了以后我就感觉他可不会对早还有很操心，
可能像我父亲一样，
只负责挣钱，
因为他在生活中连人家里面纱窗都是我自己去量一下量尺寸那种的，
量量尺寸让他去帮忙撑一下，
他都有点不耐烦的那种。
你也说了，
你俩都懒个家庭其实没有真正成熟到可以去组建一个家庭，
可以去生一个孩子的程度，
不要勉强自己啊，
你不愿意跟他亲近，
不愿意跟他过夫妻生活，
很多东西他是你没法勉强自己的，
日子很长的，
人生很长的。
是的，
我觉得我现在才之前是这样的，
我结婚的原因也是因为父母对我挺好，
他也对我挺好的，
我觉得作为他，
作为一个丈夫是过得很好的，
我觉得有些人可能会觉得矫情，
因为人跟人他是不一样，
他思想是不一样的，
有的人他可能觉得这样的老公就很好，
可能我经历过一些事情，
我觉得这样老公他不足以啊，
因为我我父亲他就是那种只负责挣钱的，
我造成很大的心理阴影嘛，
她就是负责挣钱，
想了什么东西都不管，
我妈妈就是一个人操持了这个家，
一边要工作，
一边还要在我照顾家里面，
我们三个小孩，
我看到这样的日子，
我感觉得都毫无希望，
我就害怕以后会是这样的情况，
所以说我特别害怕恐惧症的情况，
就是诚实的面对你自己，
你不爱他，
你不愿意跟他亲近，
那你就和平的分手，
经济上不要让对方吃亏，
做好这一步就行了，
我是这样想的，
我就想，
如果离婚的话，
我应该退多少呢，
有。
都不愿意退钱，
问问对方的意见啊，
那我想问一下三金要退吗？
因为父母说是三金的，
不用买了，
直接给我折现，
所以给我12万六，
那时候我也没想我离婚的10，
那在已经为第二年了，
我现在应该存了5万块钱吧，
里面有个那种就是不能退的那种，
退了可能钱好像退不来，
还是说可能要补折一部分钱不存。
咨询以前部财礼，
我是一张单独的卡，
没有放在一起，
分前的财产有没有动过，
是这样的，
几万块钱的自然空样，
其实呢，
很少有法律规定的特别明确啊，
说结婚一年该退多少，
最后两年该退多少，
没有那么明确的这样一个规定，
所以很多东西的话，
你们两个人先协商协商，
不行的话就打官司，
法院判一个数额也比较合适，
那三金要退吗？
他自己单独自己给我补了一个三金，
我需要退吗？
他是算一个总数的，
比如说总共是15万，
该退多少百分之多少，
相当于三金和彩礼，
他性质是一样的，
三金和彩礼它的性质在法律上的性质是一样的，
那这个事情我是想想闹到法庭上去，
我是想到我们两个互相算量，
但是我不知道具体要退多少合适，
但是我觉得全退的话，
彩礼这个事情大也可以全退，
但是我们两个结婚一年多，
我们俩存到那个大概20万吧，
我们是不是可以平分的，
因为有的时候他的工资还没我的工资高，
我一个月有时候最高能挣1万多，
他的工资每个月基本上是固定的6000块钱，
如果是你们两个人存下来的，
婚后一年。
的存款，
这个是要评分的，
好的就是彩礼三金，
我们就自己去沟通，
这也可以沟通协商，
是的，
没错啊，
好的，
谢谢哈，
再见啊，
拜拜。
因为确实现在没有一个标准说男方提退多少，
女方提退多少，
一年退多少，
一年半退多少，
两年退多少，
他没有形成一个全国性的标准，
这个就是两口子协商，
协商能成法院就认账，
或者说法律上就认账，
协商不成那就得打官司，
像他这种情况的话，
我估摸着打官司我至少得退一半吧，
我不太敢下这个定论哈，
确实没有这个明确的这样一个标准，
因为男方没有过错嘛，
也没有打人，
也没有外遇，
也没有任何其他的过错，
你俩自己协商啊，
这个事情大家也不必指责，
因为身体骗不了人，
爱不爱你，
愿不愿意跟你亲近，
愿不愿意跟你较？
这事儿骗不了人啊，
他确实不爱了，
他不愿意跟较，
你说他俩捆在一起是不是更痛苦？
将来再生个孩子是不更痛苦？
还不如悬崖勒马，
还不如及时止损，
还不说清醒一点，
经济上的事儿咱们就大差不差，
让人家心里也有一个过意的去，
就是和平分手就完事了啊，
记得点赞关注哦。